une détonation entendue à des centaines
de mètres et ce n'est pas la plus forte
ce pétard fait partie de la catégorie f2
vendu exclusivement aux personnes
majeures mais il existe aussi des f3
réservé aux professionnels
introuvable dans le commerce le rayon de
ce magasin est alimentée constamment
depuis quelques jours passionnés ou
simples curieux s'y intéresse j'en
achète quand je fais ma fille je fais
toujours en retrait de la maison mais
toujours en hauteur et puis voilà elle
aime bien les couleurs elle aime bien
mais je la laisse au chaud derrière moi
c'est moi qui m'occupe d'allumer et il a
tu as peur qu'ils ont eue dès monza deux
fois l'alliance ultime au delà et celui
là l'usagé des pétards et réglementée
par un arrêté préfectoral interdiction
de les faire éclater aux abords des
établissements scolaires des crèches et
à proximité de tout autre regroupement
de personnes
les marchandes ambulantes sont souvent
interpellé par deux jeunes qui le petit
groupe
madame vous avez les btan non pas du
tout elle est en sable les enfants à
l'école
une tête l'épée temps ce sont des
problèmes je ne va pas pour les mineurs
oh mon pote
noël arrive les parents viennent enfin
de poulets par an pour l'état et par
vous les enfants
les accidents liés à la manipulation de
pétards et de feux d'artifice sont
fréquents les jeunes souvent veulent
temps allumé plusieurs en même temps
certains accidents sont dramatiques des
blessures superficielles aux amputations